- Notes to the ladies, do not
wear mascaras and eyeliners.
- I haven't cried as much
in the past four days as
I have in maybe my life.
I don't know.
That was crazy.
I'm here one more day.
Got some meetings lined up.
And I'll take you guys with me.
What's up LA?
(people cheering)
(upbeat music)
- Good morning, Believe Nation.
What time is it?
- [Nina] I don't know.
- Just before 8 o'clock.
- [Nina] It's 11:00.
- Toronto time, but LA
time it's 8 o'clock?
I slept okay.
There's Nina.
She's getting ready.
We got to go in 25 minutes or so.
We're excited.
Just researching things to expect.
Sounds like it's going
to be a lot of crazy
and I can't bring the camera.
So, I'll take some pictures along the way
and then report back
tonight how everything went.
- I'm scared.
- You're scared?
- Yeah.
- It's good.
- Why?
- You got to do something that scares you.
- Yeah.
- You're checking your
makeup in the camera?
- Yeah.
- I already did my makeup before.
I woke up before Nina, did my
makeup and I'm ready to go.
All right, exciting, here we go.
Day one, we're scared.
All right, what's up everyone?
It's day one.
What day is it?
- [Lily] Day four.
- Day ...
- [Nina] Day five.
- Day five because we started filming ...
I don't remember.
I filmed nothing.
I filmed zero on this.
- I filmed something.
- You did?
- [Lily] Yes!
- Yeah, I filmed something.
I filmed you guys dancing.
I filmed the stuff ...
I filmed a little bit.
- Enter Nina's footage now.
(dramatic music)
Welcome back!
Okay, I took no video footage.
It's crazy here.
We start our days at ...
We wake up at what time?
Seven something?
- Earlier than my normal work time.
- And the conference goes until ...
- Ten thirty, 11:30.
The first day was midnight, right?
After midnight.
- Straight, like, the first day
there was not a single break.
- No, no.
- No break until midnight.
- Yeah.
- No break.
It's crazy.
So, I've been way behind on my emails.
I didn't make a single video.
Also wanted to enjoy the
experience in documenting it.
Felt like that was taken away.
I felt like there was a lot of content.
So, I'm making a video now.
It's on our last day.
Well, last day for Nina.
Nina goes home tomorrow.
- Last day for everyone but him.
- Everybody goes home except me.
I'll take you guys on my
rest of the journey in LA.
But let's go around.
Nina, what did you learn?
- What did I learn?
It was outstanding
There's a lot of stuff.
- What are you going to take away?
- Limiting belief.
Don't let that inner
voice overtake your ...
(piano playing)
Oh my God, what's it?
The real you.
The truth you.
- Wow!
Nina's excited, look at that.
- It's overwhelming, but it's good.
I feel good.
There's a lot of stuff
that you won't expect
to take from this event.
I was crying so much
that my mascara and my eyeliner
all smudge over my face.
Notes to the ladies,
do not wear mascaras and eyeliners.
- You can get waterproof ones.
Notes to the ladies,
there's waterproof versions.
- Waterproof, yeah.
- Okay, I know this.
I'm putting lemon on my salad.
We're eating.
We all got salad.
Part of the end is they challenge you
to do a 10-day challenge
of basically healthy eating of no ...
What can we have?
No caffeine, no coff ...
No caffeine, no coffee,
no dairy, no sugars.
- No meat.
- No meats.
And what else we're not
doing anything with flour.
So, it really limits
your options for 10 days.
But we got salads.
There's mine.
There's Nina's.
And there's Lily's,
which is a good segue over to Lily.
How was your experience, Lily?
- It was outstanding.
It was really good, really good.
The thing that I actually really learned
about myself is that I was making up
all these stories in my head.
I was letting it control me.
I was ...
Nobody wanted to listen to my voice.
People didn't want to hear my message.
Nobody cares.
All that stuff and I realized
it held me back from
doing a lot of things.
I wanted to launch a
YouTube video, channel,
which I didn't do because,
I'm like, nobody wants
to hear what I want to say.
I have nothing important to say.
I don't do well on my Snapchat videos
because nobody wants to say ...
Nobody wants to know what I've got to say.
But more importantly,
I don't help people
who I think could do so much better
because I assume they don't want
to hear what I have to say.
And as a result,
I allow them to be in their state
and their situation and I
just watch from the sidelines.
So, no more, okay?
I have something to say
and what it is I want to say is
that I believe that every single person
have the power within them
to be extraordinary and that's my message
to everybody and that's
what I want to say.
(people cheering)
- [Evan] Deep in the dark there,
we've got Alex playing the piano.
Alex!
- Yeah.
- [Evan] I'm zooming in on you.
Oh, he's coming out.
- [Alex] What's up?
- [Evan] This is Alex.
You guys know Alex.
What did you take away?
What did you learn?
What do you want to tell?
- I'm going to pour myself a
drink as I tell you the story.
- [Evan] All right.
- So, what did I learn?
There's a lot.
There's a ton of notes.
Woo, Nina, you want some wine,
as she takes a bottle of wine too?
So, what I learned ...
I lost my voice multiple times,
but that didn't stop me from yelling
and going full out.
And, jeez, I became aware
of how many limiting
beliefs I have and how ...
How I've never really
been aware of myself.
It's a weird thing to say.
But especially in the
last day right at the end,
we were supposed to have this conversation
with our future self or ourselves
and just recognize ourselves
and I've never really done that.
And it made me super emotional.
I started crying.
Like, I've never talked to
myself and been proud of myself.
I'm finding that out
as I'm continuously growing as a leader,
as I'm trying to be a great role model,
as I'm trying to build something amazing
and have a safe place for people.
I'm really hard on myself
and I think that there
should be a fine balance
between not being satisfied
and wanting to grow,
but not feeling like a failure.
And, so, for me, one of the things
that was an issue a lot
was I've always had trouble
receiving compliments from people.
Every time I'd get a compliment,
in my mind, I'd be like, well,
I'm still procrastinating,
I'm still doing all these bad things
and I don't feel I deserve.
I'd feel ashamed even though
they're sharing their love.
And so one of the things
that came out for me was
I deserve to be proud.
There's a lot of things
that I've accomplished,
there's a lot of difficulties
that I went through.
It's hard to realize that.
That I've thought so little of myself.
So that was one of the
things that I realized.
There's a bunch of other things,
like I'm quitting smoking.
That's another thing.
One of the biggest focuses for me
on these four days was you need
to put in motion into whatever
you want to accomplish.
Accept that motivation is
not going to carry through.
Motivation, you know,
like, will start you up.
You're like, "All right,
I'm going to go to the gym.
I'm going to wake up," and, boom,
two three days you start to do it,
which has been a problem of mine,
but you drop out.
So, there's a part of putting in motion
everything that you do.
It's not just like,
"Oh, I got to go to the gym,"
"Oh, I got to do this,"
"Oh, I got to do this."
And it's like this anger and angst
and discomfort and my whole body right now
is just like crumbling inside.
So, being aware of that
and catching yourself
and catching the language
that you use, and then from
there, seeing the vision
of you already accomplishing those things,
which I've never really done.
Like, so I want to get fit,
whatever that means to me.
I have to make a clear thing.
This is what fit means for me.
On a side note, actually, I've realized
that I want to think about fitness.
I want to have more energy.
I want to have more energy myself.
I don't want to be tired during the day.
I don't want to take naps.
For me to want to do something
to make a big life change
like the smoking or whatever,
I need to have enough emotion,
I need to hate it enough,
I need to have enough angst
in it to be like, that's it.
I'm quitting this for myself.
I'm actually making
this change for myself.
So, it's funny to realize
that there's this level
of pain that you need
to experience and there's
a level of discomfort
you need to feel in
order to make a change.
I realized in this event
that you can induce that.
Just as much as I can make myself happy,
I can go, "Yeah, woo!"
I can go energetic, right?
But I can also bring it down.
So, I'm in control of my body.
So, you can create these emotions
if you want to make a change.
So, if you feel like, you know,
I'm not happy with my body.
I'm not happy with this.
You start to go to the gym.
January, New Year's resolution, whatever.
You start going, you drop out.
And you hate yourself,
and you hate yourself
and you start to eat more and do whatever.
Whatever, everybody has their own cycles.
I have my cycles.
It's being like, you know what?
This is not enough.
Now, let me picture what the
worst case scenarios are.
In five or ten years,
if I can continue doing this,
what's my life going to be like?
How's it going to look?
Am I going to be happy?
And you start to feel the pain for that.
And you're like, Jesus, you know?
Excuse me, you know?
In five or ten years, you
know, your loved one left you.
Maybe you're thinking you're battling with
is you're not happy with your career.
You're coming home and
then all your family
who love you very much,
your friends, whatever,
your next door neighbor,
whoever cares about you
and your life and they're
seeing you unhappy
and you start to suck them in.
And they start to pull back.
In five or ten years, you imagine
yourself being left alone.
Is that enough to make
a change in your life.
And so for me, there's a bunch of moments
where I've experienced deep emotion,
just crying for my soul,
just being in discomfort and pain,
but it was a good thing because I saw
the light at the end.
Tony pointed this out.
He mentioned that he hates
being called "motivational speaker."
Motivation is not enough.
You need to create plans.
You need to create strategies.
You need to break bad behaviors.
You need to break those things
that you fall into patterns of.
So, it's like you coming home,
you grabbing a beer and
every time you think
of coming home, you're opening that fridge
and you grabbing that beer.
So, you got to cut those bad behaviors
and cut those patterns and whatever.
You're hitting the snooze button,
you're sleeping in late, whatever.
So, emotion is important
to give you enough pain
to make the change.
And then you got to create a plan.
You got to create a strategy.
I hate this thing.
Why do I want to change it?
Why is it important to me?
Okay, how do I make it
and accept that you're
not going to necessarily
always wake up every morning and like,
all right, I got to go to
the gym, blah blah blah.
But, if you focus on the
emotion of why I do this
where I'm headed and you
see yourself down there,
you see yourself in that success
in five or ten years, you're celebrating
with your friends and you're happy.
You have that house or whatever it is
that you want, then that can be enough.
It's an incredible adventure.
It's funny.
I think even if you're not open-minded
and you go to it, you get
sucked in to the energy.
You get sucked in to the
raw power of the event.
Just be open-minded
and go with a sense of
wonder and curiosity.
And whatever happens at the end, you know,
I'm sure, you know, it seemed
when they were talking about
the things that they learned,
it seems like it's all
a little bit different,
it's all interpretations.
So, whatever you learn,
it could be completely different
from what I'm saying right now.
But, yeah, it's something
you don't really want
to miss out on.
It's something that's going to...
You know, I don't want to
say "change your life".
That's one of those things
that they were talking about.
You grow, you can't change.
You just bring out the beauty inside you.
Bring out the happiness inside you
and you believe that
you deserve it, right?
So, I'm not going to say
you're going to go there
and you're going to change,
but you're going to grow.
And I think that if you ever want
to improve your life,
the important thing is
that you got to invest in yourself.
And so this event blew me away.
Blew me away.
And I'm really grateful for that.
I would come back to this event next year
and I'll bring my family, my brother.
I'll bring my fianceé, Rosanna.
Just for them to go.
Not because they're not perfect.
It's not about that.
But it's ust so ...
It's so overwhelming and beautiful
that just being around that
is just worth it in itself.
- [Evan] You come back next year,
it'll be with Rosanna, your wife.
- Yeah. It will be.
I'm getting married ...
Oh, thank you.
We're getting married on ...
In September.
Yeah, getting married in September.
Got to plan a honeymoon.
Maybe Evan's going to
pay for the honeymoon.
I don't know.
We'll discuss it later.
(laughing)
- [Alex] What's so funny, Evan?
- [Evan] Edwin is there as well.
What did you think, Edwin?
What did you learn?
What are you take away?
- I think the energy level
that is expected of us is something
that I'm taking away.
Emotionally, I went up and down a lot.
Physically, I can't believe
I have that much energy.
I think most of it is knowing
what the standard is, now
and how low we were before.
Yeah, that's the biggest
thing I've learned.
- So, what did I learn?
What did I learn from this?
So, I came to this
because we've done a lot of content
on a lot of different successful people,
and I was never really interested
in going to see any of them live,
but I felt with Tony there
would be a different experience.
I told these guys that earlier.
But, as much as I love Gary V
or any of these speakers,
I've seen their full events
and I don't feel like the vibe
is that amazing that you need to be there
versus people who just watch video.
And I wanted to see if
Tony would be different
because I've consumed
a lot of Tony content.
A lot of the stuff he talked about,
the content I never really heard before,
and so I wasn't taking ...
I wasn't filling up the notebook,
but I wanted to experience it.
And there's also a lot
that you are not ready
for when you first go.
- No, it so unexpected.
- No matter what you
think is going to happen,
it's going to get crazier.
I haven't cried as much
in the past four days
as I have in maybe my life.
I don't know.
That was crazy.
Both happy crying and sad crying.
And you can't really explain it.
You got to show up and do it.
One thing that I learned
that was really interesting
for me was the impact of my parents.
And they're on my wall at my office
and Believe came from them.
They always told me I
was really a Carmichael.
I could do anything I wanted.
That's why they're up there
and the source of Believe is them, too.
But one interesting thing that came out
where I realized that the
need to do something important
and the drive to make a
difference also comes from my mom.
One of my earlier memories.
I was, like, eight years old
and I created this little family newspaper
and I decided I was
going to make a newspaper
for the family because we always got
The Toronto Star delivered.
I wanted our own family newspaper.
And I interviewed my mom
and I asked her why she wanted
to do what she wanted to do.
So, she was a lawyer and I asked her,
"Why did you want to be a lawyer?"
And she corrected me, you know,
eight-year-old Evan, and said,
"I don't want to be just a lawyer.
I want to be a constitutional lawyer."
And she said
that she wanted to be
a constitutional lawyer
because those are the
people who change the laws.
They were the ones who went
and wrote the new laws,
and not just living
within the law system,
but creating new better,
more fair, more just laws.
And that's what she wanted to do.
And I remember thinking,
yeah, I like that.
I want to do something important too.
I want to have an impact, too.
I want to do something big.
And I just realized
this weekend that's kind
of the source of me wanting
to do a lot of big things
and not just believing in people,
but doing it in a big way.
So, I'm going to try to see
what I can find one of those ...
If I can find that old
copy of that newspaper,
that would be pretty cool.
I'm nto really memento...
I threw away most of my stuff.
I don't really have deep attachment to it
and I hope I didn't throw that away.
So, we'll see.
These guys are leaving tomorrow.
- You know what I just noticed?
Everyone is still wearing their tag.
- [Lily] Oh, nice.
- [Evan] Alex and Lily leave when?
- Tomorrow at 4:00 am.
Because the flight is at seven, right?
- And then Nina and Edwin are leaving ...
When are you leaving?
- Um, 9 o'clock?
- [Edwin] The plane leaves at 11:45.
- Yeah, but we have to leave
here around nine o'clock.
- Done deal.
- I'm going to do one more day.
Got some meetings lined up.
And I'll take you guys with me.
(airy music)
It's past midnight which is
actually 3:00 a.m. Toronto time.
We had some awesome conversations.
Alex and Lily went to bed already.
They have to wake up really early.
I think they're going to get up
in a couple of hours, actually.
They have their flight.
So, Nina and I are going to head
to bed and start our next day.
Good morning, good morning, good morning,
good morning, good morning.
We had our morning routine.
We shook it up today.
We woke up to birds, right?
- Loons.
- A minute of loons.
Then we did a party song.
♫ Party song and dance for three minutes.
And then we did ...
yeah.
- The Lion King.
- Oh, right.
Then we woke up to the ...
(singing intro to The Lion King)
then brushed our teeth, then we danced.
And then we did Gratitude Song.
So, it was good.
It was our test.
Morning routine experiment started today.
Edwin, how are we doing today?
- Thanks to our Uber, we're doing great.
- Oh, Edwin and Lily ...
And Lily, wow.
Edwin and Nina
- [Nina] Lily, wow, oh my God.
- I'm so used to Edwin and Lily
being together and everything.
Edwin and Nina are going home together.
I'm staying one more day.
They're going to Uber to the airport.
I'm going to Uber to Beverly Hills
and we're all going to
have an amazing day.
(everyone cheers)
(driving music)
All right, so I'm here in Beverly Hills.
I'm outside the offices
of Imagine Entertainment behind me
and I'm meeting at 11:15 the
co-founder, Brian Grazer.
He reached out to me a while ago
and said, "Hey, if you're in
LA, I'd like to meet you."
I don't really know what the context is.
Just he likes meeting interesting people
and so I was picked.
But I'm excited to meet him.
So, he's the co-founder
of Imagine Entertainment.
They've won all sorts of awards.
He was named Time Magazine's one
of the most influential people.
And, yeah, super pumped to see him,
but I've got two hours to burn until then,
so I'm going to go get some breakfast,
which is going to be hard
because I can't really have most
of the foods I usually eat on
this 10-day thing that I'm on.
So, we'll see.
Maybe a banana.
Banana for breakfast.
Here we go.
(upbeat music)
So, I'm walking on the
street in Beverly Hills.
I need sunglasses.
It's bright for the first time, first day.
Really crazy hot and
bright in LA, this trip.
I love it.
Walking down the street,
come across this place.
Pavilions.
Grocery store.
Got to get some breakfast to
maybe load up for the day.
Here we go.
All right. I'm done.
You guys want to see what I bought?
I've got a veggie tray.
I've got roasted and salted mixed nuts.
I have a thing of bananas.
That's what I'm going to eat.
I'm sure Nina's really laughing
at this part of my product
selection, but it's healthy,
it sticks to the diet,
and I'm going to enjoy it.
(Latino music)
So, I've decided to stop
off at Peet's Coffee.
I told Nina.
She freaked out.
It's not coffee, it's herbal tea.
Africa Rooibos something.
It's actually pretty good.
Got some work done.
Ate my veggies and now it's time
to go meet Mr. Brian Grazer
and see what he wants to talk about.
I'm excited.
All right, well, that was fun.
We chatted for an hour,
which seemed to go really quickly.
He's a pretty cool guy.
Pretty chill.
I didn't even know why we were meeting.
And he has an interesting story
where he likes to find people
that he finds interesting
and have conversations with them.
And so he just wanted to meet with me
and what he said was he
loved the Top 10 Rules,
videos that we put together.
He had a request for
one to add to the list.
So, we're going to be making one for him.
Maybe one for his son, too,
which will be intereting.
He just wanted to know the story.
Why I started it.
His favorite one was Bruce
Lee, which was interesting.
It's been a while since
we did anything on Bruce.
And it was super cool.
It's good to know that the
videos are being watched.
It's always great to see
people loving the videos
and having an impact by watching them,
and looking forward to
new ones coming out.
So, stay tuned for his
request of a Top 10.
And now it's ...
What, I got 45 mintues
to meet with Louis Howes.
He's another fellow YouTuber,
and he's a podcaster.
I had him on my channel a while ago.
And, that's it.
I'm still feeling full
from those vegetables, so, pretty good.
Sticking to the diet so far.
Day two, yeah.
(light music)
All right, I'm at Louis' place.
Let's do it.
- What is up everyone?
I'm Louis Howes here.
Very excited about this interview.
We've got Evan Carmichael in the house.
What's up, brother?
- I'm good, man.
What is it, right hand to left?
- Make it awkward.
- All right, just got out.
That was a fun session.
Louis' second hangout ever.
The last one we did was
three or four years ago.
So, it was good.
I showed him how to do it.
We had some live questions,
great audience and a great guy.
And apparantly he's coming
to Toronto some point soon.
September, something like that.
So, we'll maybe plan something
else when he comes up.
So, I'm going to head
back to Beverly Hills,
into the coffee shop, get
a little bit of work done
and then prepare to meet some fans.
I love meeting fans when I travel.
So, we'll see who shows up,
make a video and I'm pumped.
Let's do it.
(light music)
What's up, LA?
(everyone cheers)
So we met some fans,
and before people start kicking off,
I wanted to pass around the camera.
They're going to introduce themselves,
what they do, and what their one word is.
He's going first because
his parking's running out.
- I'm Brian, I'm an investor
and my one word is "invest".
- Hi, I'm Lalaine Lao
and my company's Access A T,
eco-friendly t-shirts
and my word is "believe".
- Hi, I'm Arman.
I'm the founder of Swab Lube.
My one word is "persistence".
- Hi, my name's Ed Reyes.
I'm 2017 nominee
for Man of the Year for
Leukemia Lymphoma Society.
My one word is "hero" #imaherobeahero.
- Hello, my name is
Kenisha, Chosen Culture.
I'm a life coach also with Caber Group
and my one word is "love".
- What's up Believe Nation,
this is Devon Trish.
I'm a Virgo.
I'm an actor.
My one word, I'm still working on it.
- Hi, I'm Skylar Ojeda.
I'm a writer and I would say
my one word is also "love".
- Hi, my name's Jonathan Chu
and I work at Disney Imagineering
and I also started a
company called Choose Joy,
based off of our last name.
So, my one word is "hope".
- Hello, I'm Mandy Chu, also a founder
of Choose Joy and my one
word is "expression".
- Hi, I'm Thelma Saunders.
I am an owner of Thousand
Oaks Fit Body Boot Camp
and my one word is "flourish".
- Well, my name's Marilyn and
my word is "perseverance".
- [Evan] Yeah, all right.
LA in the house.
We're going to get back to talking now.
All right, that was a lot of fun.
It's always so humbling to meet the fans.
This was a really good group.
Man, I love the LA fans.
That was a really good group.
People showed up.
We had a great time.
I answered a lot of questions,
got to know some new entrepreneurs.
People drove from quite a distance, some
of them to get there.
It's humbling.
I started at four.
Started at four.
First person came at
four, what time is it now?
It's eight.
Four hours.
One of the things that I find is
I get more energy with time.
Like at the beginning,
I still have energy.
It's good to meet people
and then it picks up.
I get my energy and now I'm on fire
and then I'm going to go
home and crash at some point.
But no, just an amazing experience.
These guys were awesome
and looking forward to
coming back again one day.
See how it goes.
I'm going to head to
the grocery store again,
that last place that I was at,
apparently has a lot of good
feedback and good reviews.
So, I'm going to see what else I can find
and head home, see what Nina's up to,
catch up on work and then get ready
to fly back to Toronto.
(peppy music)
All right, I'm finally back.
Had a little bit of a
chaotic episode there.
My visa got cut off.
I didn't call Visa to let them know
I was coming to the US
and they cut me off.
I had to figure out a way
to call and get it fixed.
But look at this.
Here's what I bought.
I bought a green drink.
Keep on my diet.
I bought some more nuts for tomorrow.
I bought one giant avocado.
I bought another veggie tray
that I can eat right now
and, Nina's going to love this,
I bought green beans and onions.
I thought they were mushrooms.
Onions and mushrooms
that I'm going to cook.
We did zero cooking this entire time.
Every meal was eaten out.
Zero cooking, so I'm going to make
the first cooked meal of this trip.
Here I go.
Okay, so I burned the thing I was supposed
to cook pretty badly.
I added some water to it and we'll see.
I miss Nina for many reasons.
I'm going to relax, eat
the rest of my food,
watch an episode of Billions
because Nina doesn't like it.
So, I have a chance to watch it here.
That's it.
Get ready for bed.
Wake up tomorrow morning
and head back home, woo!
I mixed some avocado in with it
and it's actually not that bad.
Good night.
Good morning, good morning, good morning.
It's the last day.
I am so excited I get to go home.
Get to see Nina.
Last night was interesting.
I'm a bit lonely which is interesting.
It's an interesting
different feeling, I think
from having all of the intense experiences
over the past number of
days, especially with Nina.
Have a night just be by myself
and a morning by myself, I
really, really miss Nina.
I want to get back.
I mean, I always miss Nina when I go away,
but I actually feel loneliness.
What am I going to do?
Last night I fell asleep.
I stayed up late watching
episodes of Billions
when I was supposed to work.
I wanted to work.
But I ended up staying up
watching episodes of Billions.
So, when I'm lonely, i
veg on TV, apparently.
Interesting.
I'm going to get my
Uber, head to the airport
and go home and see Nina.
Woo!
(guitar music)
All right, I'm done, woo!
Got naseaous on the plane.
Fighting a headache from all
the turbulance, up and down.
But it's good to be back.
I'm excited.
Let's go see Nina.
(music)
- Hi.
- [Evan] Long time no see
- [Nina] Long time no see.
(kissing)
- I'm happy to see the wife.
Okay.
Well, thank you guys for
joining us on another trip.
No more trips for a while.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- Nina's going
on a trip by herself.
- No, with you.
We'll document everything.
Evan is done traveling for a while.
- What's while?
- Like two years.
- Yeah, right.
You're going soon.
- No.
- You're going to in a couple of months.
- Okay, it was fun, though.
It was a good trip.
We learned a lot.
Met some good people.
I'm very thankful for the trip
and it's great to see the wife.
She's back.
I'm back.
We're back together.
- I came back yesterday.
I came back yesterday.
- I got to get some food too.
Thank you guys for joining us
- Continue to believe, much love
and whatever your one word is.
- And we'll see you soon.
(swooshing)